This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In Chinese mythology, Meng Po is sometimes known as the goddess of oblivion. She polices the land of the dead and has a special responsibility. She makes sure that souls on their way to being reincarnated do not remember their past lives. To ensure this, she prepares a soup with five ingredients. Her five-flavored soup of oblivion produces immediate and permanent amnesia. The soul can now proceed to be reincarnated with no memory of previous lives.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。在中国神话中，孟婆有时被称为遗忘女神。她巡视阴曹地府，并承担着一项特殊的职责。她要确保那些即将投胎转世的灵魂不记得他们的前世。为了做到这一点，她用五种成分熬制了一种汤。她那五味俱全的忘情汤能让人产生即刻且永久的失忆。这样一来，灵魂就可以带着对前世的零记忆继续投胎转世了。
There are rare occasions when spirits fail to drink the five-flavored soup, and when these souls are reincarnated, they become humans who can remember their past lives. Nearly every culture in the world has stories and legends about memory and forgetfulness. Our ability to remember long-ago events is a signature accomplishment of the brain. Our inability to remember important things is an endless source of frustration. Today on the show, and in a companion story on Hidden Brain Plus,
极少数情况下，会有幽灵未能喝下这五味汤，而当这些灵魂转世时，他们就会成为能够记起前世的人。世界上几乎每一种文化都有关于记忆和遗忘的故事与传说。我们记住远期事件的能力是大脑标志性的成就。而我们无法记住重要事情则成了无尽挫折的来源。今天的节目中，以及《隐藏的大脑Plus》的番外故事中，
we examine the science of forgetting. We look at why our minds hold on to some memories for a lifetime, but discard others within seconds. And we answer a question many people ask themselves, is my forgetfulness a sign that something is wrong with me? Forgetting to remember and remembering to forget, this week on Hidden Brain. In Charles Dickens' novel, Great Expectations, we are introduced to the character Miss Havisham. Many years earlier, she was jilted at the altar on her wedding day.
我们将探讨遗忘的科学。我们来看看为什么我们的大脑能把某些记忆保留一辈子，却在几秒钟内抛弃其他记忆。我们还将回答许多人经常自问的一个问题：我的健忘是否表明我的身体出了毛病？忘记去记住，记住去忘记，本周的《隐藏的大脑》。在查尔斯·狄更斯的小说《远大前程》中，我们认识了郝薇香小姐这个角色。多年前，她在婚礼当天被新郎在圣坛前抛弃。
She becomes obsessed with this moment and cannot move on from it. She surrounds herself with reminders of that day, wearing her wedding dress and keeping the clock stopped at the exact moment of her wedding. In so doing, she becomes consumed with sadness. She becomes a prisoner of her own memories. The memories we carry say a lot about who we are and how we see the world. At University College Dublin, and how we see the world. At University College Dublin, psychologist Kira Green studies how memories are formed and the roles that both remembering
她对这一刻执迷不悟，无法释怀。她周围全是那天事物的提醒，穿着婚纱，把时钟永远停在她婚礼的那个确切时刻。正因如此，她被悲伤吞噬了。她成了自己记忆的囚徒。我们所承载的记忆很大程度上说明了我们是谁以及我们是如何看待世界的。在都柏林大学学院，以及我们是如何看待世界的。在都柏林大学学院，心理学家基拉·格林研究了记忆是如何形成的，以及记忆和
and forgetting play in our lives. Kira Green, welcome to Hidden Brain. Hi Shankar, thanks for having me. Kira, I wanna talk about something that happened to you some time ago. You live in Dublin and it's common for people to get around by bike. You were riding your bike on the way to a piano lesson.
遗忘在我们的生活中扮演的角色。基拉·格林，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。嗨，尚卡尔，谢谢邀请我。基拉，我想谈谈不久前发生在你身上的一件事。你住在都柏林，人们骑自行车出行很常见。你当时正骑着自行车去上钢琴课。
Can you describe the day for me? Sure. It was about three years ago and it was a rainy November night. And it was dark and it was starting to rain and it was just a kind of cold, miserable night. And I was leaving work to go to my piano lesson and I was in a rush. So, you know, I rushed down the stairs and I got down to my bike and I realized I'd forgotten my helmet. So I rushed back upstairs and all the way back up through this very large building.
你能为我描述一下那天的情况吗？当然。那是大约三年前的一个阴雨蒙蒙的11月夜晚。天很黑，开始下雨，而且是一个既寒冷又糟糕的夜晚。我正离开公司去上钢琴课，当时我很赶。所以，你知道的，我匆忙跑下楼，来到我的自行车旁，却发现我忘带头盔了。于是我又匆忙跑上楼，穿过这栋非常大的建筑跑回楼上。
I got my helmet, went back down. So then I was running late for my lessons. Keira started zipping through the night to her class. The roads were slick. I was cycling through Donnybrook, which is a kind of a busy road. on that road there's a lot of buses, there's a lot of cars, there's a lot of cyclists. What there isn't on that part of the road is a bicycle lane. The bicycle lane had stopped earlier. So in fact as I was cycling along I was weaving around traffic and in round buses. around traffic and in around buses. So I was cycling on wet roads, going too fast and you can probably see where this is going
我拿到了头盔，又跑回楼下。所以当时我去上课已经迟到了。基拉开始骑着车在夜色中飞驰赶往课堂。路面很湿滑。我正骑车穿过多尼布鲁克，那是一条比较繁忙的路上。那条路上有很多公交车，有很多汽车，有很多骑自行车的人。那段路上没有的是一条自行车道。自行车道在前面就已经中断了。事实上，当我骑车前行时，我不得不穿梭于车流和公交车之间。穿梭于车流和公交车之间。所以我骑在湿滑的路上，车速太快，你大概能猜到接下来会发生什么
because I skidded on the bike and I skidded right in front of a bus which fortunately didn't hit me but it was one of those e-bikes, an electric bike that has the electric power in it which means it's very heavy, the down tube is really heavy. So as I fell, my leg got caught in the down tube and snapped my leg in half. It's like if you could imagine a little small bunch of twigs and then you snap those twigs, they don't snap cleanly, they snap with shards. And I had this very strange experience where I, you know, I've heard of this happening before, but I'd never experienced it, where I, you know, I've heard of this happening before, but I'd never experienced it where I didn't feel the pain straight away. I was lying on the ground and you know, you get that moment of shock.
因为我的自行车打滑了，就滑在一辆公交车的前面，幸运的是它没有撞到我，但那是一辆电动自行车，车里有电力驱动装置，这意味着它非常重，下管非常重。所以当我摔倒时，我的腿卡在了下管里，把我的腿当场折断了。就像如果你能想象一小捆树枝，然后你把那些树枝折断，它们不会干净利落地断掉，而是会带着碎屑断裂。我当时有一种非常奇怪的体验，你知道的，我以前听说过这种事发生，但我从未亲身经历过，你知道的，我听说过这种事发生，但我从未亲身经历过我没有立刻感到疼痛。我躺在地上，你知道的，你会经历那一刻的休克。
And I was lying on the ground and I tried to stand up and I couldn't stand up. And I didn't know why I couldn't stand up. And then I looked down and my shoe had come off somewhere. I don't know where it had gone. My shoe had come off. But my leg was dangling like a stuffed sock. The bus driver came rushing out and he was like, are you okay? And I was like, well, no, I think I broke my leg. But it still didn't hurt. And then it was only a little while later that the pain started to come in. The bus driver called 999, so we called the emergency services,
我躺在地上，试图站起来，却站不起来。我不知道为什么自己站不起来。然后我低头一看，我的鞋子不知道掉到哪里去了。我不知道它去哪儿了。我的鞋子掉了。但我的腿就像一只塞满东西的袜子一样晃荡着。公交车司机冲了过来，问道：“你没事吧？”我说：“好吧，没事，我想我把腿摔断了。”但它还是不疼。然后过了一会儿，疼痛才开始袭来。公交车司机拨打了999，所以我们呼叫了紧急服务，
but it took nearly an hour for the ambulance to get there because it was a very busy, wet evening, so they were snarled up in traffic. As Ciara waited in the rain for the ambulance to fight its way through traffic, she started to experience the kind of pain she had never dreamed possible. This incredibly sharp, overwhelming, almost electric pain. And I suppose it's because it's nerve pain, essentially. It's the shards of the bone sawing against the nerve.
但救护车花了将近一个小时才赶到，因为那是一个非常繁忙且下雨的晚上，他们被堵在车流里了。当基拉在雨中等待救护车在车流中艰难前行时，她开始经历那种她做梦也没想到的痛苦。这种极其剧烈、铺天盖地、几乎带电般的疼痛。我想这是因为这本质上是神经痛。是骨头的碎屑在锯着神经。
I've never had the experience before where I would actually scream with pain but not intend to. It was completely involuntary. I'd feel like screams were being drawn out of me against my will. Just incredibly agonizing, electrifyingly sharp, overwhelming blinding pain. You know in a hospital where they ask you, you know, how's the pain on a scale of 1 to 10? My previous 10 was now a 6 on the broken leg scale of 1 to 10. Around midnight, doctors decided to try and set the leg. They told Kiera they would give her anaesthesia. I'm allergic to one of the most common anaesthetic,
我以前从未有过这样的经历：疼得大叫，却又不是故意的。那是完全不由自主的。我感觉尖叫声违背我的意愿从我体内被抽离出来。简直是痛不欲生、电击般锐利、铺天盖地且让人双眼失明的剧痛。你知道在医院里，他们会问你：“按1到10分来算，疼痛程度是多少？”我以前的10分，现在在断腿的1到10分疼痛量表里只能算作6分。大约在午夜时分，医生决定尝试为她接骨。他们告诉基拉会给她进行麻醉。我对最常见的麻醉剂之一过敏，
so they said we'll try ketamine. I'd never had ketamine before, and I'm sure if you're taking this for recreational purposes, that maybe it's a good time if you're starting out in a, in a happy state and you're comfortable and relaxed with friends. But if you're starting out in a state of fear and pain, it was terrifying. It was a really, really terrifying experience. It felt like it lasted about a thousand years. It was I, you know, had this this incredibly vivid hallucinations and I, you know, came to believe at one point
所以他们说我们试试氯胺酮。我以前从未用过氯胺酮，而且我敢肯定，如果你是为了消遣而服用这个，那也许在你一开始处于快乐状态、感觉舒适并与朋友放松时是个好时机。但如果你一开始处于恐惧和疼痛的状态，那就太可怕了。那真是一次非常非常可怕的经历。感觉持续了大约一千年。我，你知道的，有着这种极其生动的幻觉，而且我，你知道的，一度开始相信
that like I had ceased to exist, that I no longer existed. And I could I could feel not pain, but pressure, which obviously in retrospect was pressure on my leg as I tried to set it. But it felt to me like I was being compressed through, I felt like I was a train being compressed through a train tunnel. And it was, it was this really, really surreal and very frightening experience. And I've had a lot of flashbacks to that experience since. And then after all that, it didn't work. They tried to set my leg and they put it in plaster, but it didn't work. So then they said, actually, after all that, we need to do surgery anyway.
就像我已经不复存在了，我不再存在了。我能感觉到，不是疼痛，而是压力，回想起来这显然是对我腿部的压力，因为他们试图为我正骨。但对我来说，感觉就像我被压缩着穿过，我感觉自己像一列火车被压缩着穿过一条火车隧道。那种感觉，真的是一种非常超现实、非常吓人的经历。从那以后，我做过很多关于那次经历的闪回。然后经历了这一切之后，它没有起作用。他们试图为我的腿正骨并打上了石膏，但没有成功。所以他们说，实际上，经历了这一切之后，无论如何我们都得做手术。
I'm assuming there must have been a very lengthy period of rehab after this much work on your leg, Keira. Yeah, so I mean, I couldn't walk at all for several months. I was on crutches then afterwards for six months. And there was very extensive physiotherapy and rehab and so on. It's three years later now and I do still have pain in my leg. It's much, much better and I don't limp anymore mostly. I can walk fine, but I used to dance and I used to do things that I can't do anymore. So it has had a lot of knock on consequences in my life. More than I think, I think previously I would have used the expression, you know,
基拉，在你的腿经历如此大规模的治疗之后，我想一定有一个非常漫长的康复期吧。是的，我的意思是，我有好几个月完全无法走路。后来我拄了六个月的拐杖。还有非常大量的物理治疗和康复训练等等。现在已经是三年后了，我的腿确实仍然会痛。它好多了，而且我大部分时间都不再瘸了。我能正常走路，但我以前跳舞，还能做一些我现在做不了的事情。所以它在我的生活中产生了许多连锁反应。比我想象的要多，我想以前我可能会用这样的表述，你知道的，
somebody breaking a leg. Oh, you might break a leg. And you think it's, you know, unpleasant, but not a huge deal. But it was quite life altering in a lot of ways. I'm wondering how the memories of this event have stayed with you. Have you been able to get back on a bike?
有人骨折了。哦，你可能会骨折。你会觉得这，你知道的，很不愉快，但不是什么大不了的事。但在很多方面，这彻底改变了生活。我想知道这段经历的记忆是如何留在你身上的。你还能重新骑上自行车吗？
Have you been able to go back to the place where the accident took place? What's happened? Yeah, so definitely the memories have stayed with me. I'll find myself kind of repeatedly thinking about parts of it. In terms of getting back on a bike, well, of course couldn't for a long time because physically I was totally unable to. I was in a wheelchair for a while and then I had crutches for a long time. But then maybe six, seven months after the accident I did get back on the bike. I just said, right, I'll do a short cycle from my house down to my parents' house, which is maybe a few miles, it's not very far.
你还能回到事故发生的地方吗？情况怎么样了？是的，所以这些记忆绝对留在了我心里。我会发现自己不知不觉地反复思考其中的一些部分。至于重新骑上自行车，嗯，当然很长一段时间都做不到，因为从身体上讲我完全无法做到。我坐了一段时间轮椅，然后拄了很长一段时间拐杖。但大概在事故发生六七个月后，我确实重新骑上了自行车。我当时就想，好歹，我要从我家短途骑行到我父母家，大概几英里远，不是很远。
And I did it and I was proud that I did it, but my heart was going, I just going like the clappers the whole time. And I found that I couldn't release my I had this death grip on the handlebars and I couldn't release my hands from the handlebars enough to turn right. So of course, we we drive in Ireland on the left hand side of the road. So turning left is easy enough. You just stay on the side. You on the left-hand side of the road, so turning left is easy enough. You just stay on the side you are.
我做到了，而且我为自己做到了这一点感到骄傲，但我的心一直在狂跳，整个过程就像打鼓一样怦怦直跳。我发现自己无法释放，我对车把有一种死亡般的紧握，我的手无法从车把上松开到足以向右转弯的程度。所以当然，我们在爱尔兰是在道路左侧行驶的。所以向左转弯相当容易。你只需要呆在路边。你在道路左侧行驶，所以向左转弯相当容易。你只需要呆在你所在的这一侧。
Turning right involves crossing over the road. You have to indicate. So I did it to prove to myself that I could do it, but it was such an anxiety-provoking experience that I couldn't... I feel there is a thing with a lot of activities like cycling where you need to have a sort of illusion of invulnerability in order to do it. And that illusion was completely shattered, that I knew how vulnerable I was.
向右转弯需要穿过马路。你必须打转向灯。所以我这样做是为了向自己证明我能做到，但这是一次如此引发焦虑的体验，以至于我无法……我觉得对于骑自行车这样的许多活动来说，你需要有一种刀枪不入的幻觉才能完成它。而那种幻觉彻底破灭了，我清楚地知道了自己是多么脆弱。
And there was no getting around that. There was no pretending that this was a safe thing to do. I no longer believed that it was in any way a safe thing to do. So I still have the bike and I still want to get back on it, but I've never gotten back to being able to cycle to work, for example. And when you consider sort of going on the bike, when you consider the inconvenience of parking and you say, maybe I should bike today, what happens in your mind?
这是无法回避的。没有什么可以假装这是一件安全的事情。我不再相信这在任何方面是一件安全的事情。所以我仍然有那辆自行车，我仍然想重新骑上它，但我再也没有回到能够骑车去上班的状态。当你考虑骑自行车时，当你考虑到停车的不便，然后你说，也许我今天应该骑车，你的脑海里会发生什么？
What does your mind say? Jennifer Pruitt I don't think I've even really gotten to that stage. I think if I was even to think about what I do tomorrow, because I'd have to plan, I'd have to think, well, I'll pack the bike bag and I'll pump up the tires on the know, on the bike. And just straight away, I'm just like, no, it's, it's, there's always a thing. It's particularly, I live in Ireland, it rains a lot. This is no surprise. If I look out the window and it looks like it might be wet, it might be rainy, the road might be slick. Absolutely no way. The thought of getting on the bike is, is, is really very frightening. I start to feel very anxious
你的脑海里在想什么？詹妮弗·普鲁特我甚至觉得我还没真正到那个阶段。我想如果我甚至去考虑我明天要做什么，因为我必须计划，我必须想，好吧，我会收拾好自行车包，给轮胎打气，你知道的，就在自行车上。然后立刻，我就想，不，这，这，总是有个坎。尤其是，我住在爱尔兰，雨水很多。这并不奇怪。如果我向外望去，看起来可能会湿漉漉的，可能会下雨，路面可能会滑。绝对没门。一想到要骑上自行车，就，真的非常害怕。我开始感到非常焦虑
about it. So even if I'm driving and I see people, you know, cyclists weaving around, I get so anxious on their behalf. What if they slipped? What if they fell? What if they got knocked down? What if they had an accident? But it is absorbing a good amount of my attention. You mentioned a second ago that what happened at the hospital was also in some ways very difficult, that in some ways you continue to have these memories. Are you still bothered by those memories of what happened when you received ketamine and when you were in the hospital? Yes, to a certain extent, but that I had a strange experience maybe a year and a half ago, so maybe again about a year and a half after the accident, I had laser eye surgery.
。所以即使我在开车时看到人们，你知道的，骑自行车的人在车流中穿梭，我都会替他们感到焦虑。万一他们滑倒了呢？万一他们摔倒了呢？万一他们被撞倒了呢？万一他们发生事故了呢？但它占据了我相当大的一部分注意力。你刚才提到，医院里发生的事情在某些方面也非常困难，在某些方面你仍然不断有这些记忆。你仍然会被注射氯胺酮以及在医院时发生的事情的那些记忆所困扰吗？是的，在某种程度上是的，但我大约在一年半前有过一次奇怪的经历，所以大概也是在事故发生后的一年半左右，我做了激光矫正视力手术。
It only takes about 10 minutes and it's not painful. They put anesthetic eye drops into your eyes, but obviously your eyes are open for the surgery and there's a laser coming in and doing things and there's a lot of pressure on your eye. And when they're doing that, you see strange things. Like it looks like kind of like a tunnel. You have that kind of vibe of things looking like, things are coming away from, shooting away from you or coming towards you like kind of like a tunnel. You know, you have that kind of vibe of things looking like things are coming away,
这只需要大约10分钟，而且并不痛苦。他们在你的眼睛里滴入麻醉眼药水，但显然你的眼睛在手术过程中是睁开的，有激光射进来做手术，而且你的眼睛承受着很大的压力。当他们这样做时，你会看到奇怪的东西。比如它看起来有点像一条隧道。你会有那种感觉，东西看起来像是在离你远去，离你而去或向你走来，就像一条隧道一样。你知道，你会有那种感觉，东西看起来像是在离去，
shooting away from you, are coming towards you like they're down a tunnel. And I had this almost flashback to that Ketamine experience where I told you it felt like I was being compressed and squeezed down a tunnel. And it was just the visual elements of that gave me this kind of reaction. I knew that's what was happening at the time. And I didn't have a panic attack or anything, but I was aware that it was like, God, this is like that and it made it very, very unpleasant and it felt like a long ten minutes. All of us want to have a sharp memory, but Kira's painful memories of her bike accident raise an important question.
从你身边飞速掠过，或者向你奔来，就像它们在一条隧道里一样。我几乎对那次氯胺酮的经历产生了闪回，我跟你说过，那感觉就像我被压缩着挤进了一条隧道。仅仅是其中的视觉元素就给了我这种反应。我当时就知道那是怎么回事。我没有惊恐发作或别的什么，但我意识到：“天哪，这太像那个了”，这让过程变得非常非常不愉快，感觉这10分钟极其漫长。我们所有人都希望拥有敏锐的记忆力，但基拉关于自行车事故的痛苦记忆引发了一个重要问题。
Is a sharp memory always a good thing? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. Most of us wish we could remember things better. We think of forgetting as a flaw. But being able to forget some things can be a blessing. At University College Dublin, psychologist Kira Green cites the example of a woman with an unusual ability. So Jill Price is a woman who's very well known because she has an extremely rare condition that's called highly superior autobiographical memory, which is usually abbreviated as HSAM. And what it is, is a really extraordinary memory for the events of your own life. So somebody with HSAM, like somebody like Jill, for example, will be able to tell you in enormous detail about all the incidents of their lives. Like somebody who you might be able to say, tell me what the weather was like
敏锐的记忆力总是一件好事吗？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。我们大多数人都希望自己能把事情记得更牢。我们把遗忘视为一种缺陷。但能够忘记一些事情可能是一种福气。在都柏林大学学院，心理学家基拉·格林举了一个拥有非凡能力的女性的例子。吉尔·普莱斯（Jill Price）是一个非常著名的女性，因为她患有一种极其罕见的疾病，被称为超群绝伦的自传体记忆（Highly Superior Autobiographical Memory），通常简称为HSAM。这种状况实际上是对自己生活中的事件有着非凡的记忆力。因此，患有HSAM的人，比如像吉尔这样的人，能够极其详细地向你讲述他们生活中的所有经历。就像你可以对某个人说，告诉我1998年9月30日的天气是什么样的？
on the 30th of September 1998. And most of us would go, how on earth would I possibly know that? But somebody with HSAM, someone like Jill, would say, oh, yeah, I remember. And it was really sunny. But the clouds came over at about three o'clock. We thought for a while it was going to rain, but then it didn't. And I was hanging out with my friends and my friend picked me up. And then we went off down to the shopping center and we hung out outside Clare's
我们大多数人都会想：“我怎么可能知道那是什么样的？”但患有HSAM的人，像吉尔这样的人，会说：“哦，是的，我记得。那天阳光非常灿烂。但大约三 o'clock（三点钟）时云层压了过来。我们一度以为要下雨，但后来没下。我和朋友们在一起，我的朋友开车来接我。然后我们去了购物中心，在克莱尔（Clare's）
accessories and my friend was thinking about getting her ears pierced. And, you know, would be able to give you this extremely detailed blow-by-blow account of their own personal experiences. So Jill Price wrote a memoir about her condition and in the memoir she tells a story about something that happened to her when she was a child. Tell me the story, Keira. So she tells the story that her dad used to work as the agent for Jim Henson, who of course was the creator of the Muppets and the brain behind Sesame Street. And he would tell all these kind of stories to the family and everybody all about Sesame Street and about Jim Henson and how incredible it was.
饰品店外面闲逛，我朋友当时正考虑去打耳洞。”并且，能够向你提供他们个人经历中极其详尽的逐个细节的描述。于是吉尔·普莱斯写了一本关于她这种状况的回忆录，并在回忆录中讲述了一个关于她童年时期发生的事情的故事。基拉，把这个故事讲给我听听。她讲述的故事是，她的父亲以前是吉姆·汉森（Jim Henson）的经纪人，吉姆·汉森当然是布偶秀（The Muppets）的创作者和《芝麻街》（Sesame Street）背后的智囊。他会给家人讲各种各样关于《芝麻街》和吉姆·汉森的故事，以及这一切是多么不可思议。
And at the time, Jill was very young. She was in nursery school. But her dad arranged for her whole class to go on a field trip to Jim Henson's studio where all of the puppets were created. And this, you know, they've talked it up for ages. And this is something, of course, that they were all really, really looking forward to it. But when the day came around for the field trip, Jill was sick. She had tonsillitis. So she wasn't able to go. And
当时，吉尔非常小。她还在上幼儿园。但她的父亲为她的整个班级安排了一次实地考察旅行，去参观吉姆·汉森的工作室，那里是所有木偶创作的地方。而且这个，你知道的，他们已经谈论了好久了。这当然是他们所有人都非常非常期待的事情。但当实地考察的日子到来时，吉尔生病了。她得了扁桃体炎。所以她去不了了。而且
of course, being very, very young, she didn't understand that, you know, her father had already committed to this and had already committed to take the whole class with her. So they had to go ahead without his own daughter, they had to go ahead and run the trip. And she was devastated, couldn't understand why he was doing this, taking all of her friends, leaving her behind. And even though she had tonsillitis, so she'd have really sore throat, she stood, you know, like screaming at the top of her lungs, screaming at her parents, so they were not letting them go. And she says, you know, that it was a small thing in retrospect, but that when every
由于她非常非常小，她并不理解，你知道的，她的父亲已经做出了承诺，已经承诺带着全班同学一起去。所以他们不得不抛下他自己的女儿继续前行，他们不得不按计划进行这次旅行。她伤心欲绝，无法理解他为什么要这么做，带着她所有的朋友，把她抛在后面。尽管她得了扁桃体炎，喉咙非常痛，但她还是站在那里，你知道的，声嘶力竭地尖叫，向父母尖叫，抗议他们不让他们去。她说，你知道的，回想起来这只是一件小事，但每次
time she thinks about it, she still feels this overwhelming sense of disappointment every time she sees the Muppets. So every time you see a Muppets Christmas, Carol, you're brought back to this moment. And not just a rose-tinted view of, oh, haha, this is a funny thing that happened to me as a child, but really almost being right back there again and feeling it as though she's right there in the moment. right there in the moment. Now, because she has this extraordinary memory, this extraordinary autobiographical recall for things, she remembers very vivid details
当她想到这件事时，每当她看到《木偶奇遇记》（Muppets Christmas Carol）时，她依然会感到这种铺天盖地的失望感。所以每次你看到木偶圣诞颂歌，你都会被带回那个时刻。这不仅仅是一种玫瑰色的回忆，觉得“哦，哈哈，这是我小时候发生的一件趣事”，而是真的几乎就像重新回到了那个地方，感觉就像她当时就在那个时刻一样。
about what happened that day. She remembers hearing her mother walking away from her and hearing the sound of her mother's heels as they walk away from her, really, really detailed. Now, what's striking, of course, is that when things happened to us many years ago, in time our memories start to fade. We start to forget details of it, but that seems like that's not the case for Jill. No, so it's actually, it is very unusual. Whereas, say, my memory of a childhood event might be very, very fuzzy, very foggy. I might remember kind of a core detail of that event,
就在那个时刻。现在，因为她有着非凡的记忆力，对事物有着非凡的自传体回忆能力，她能记住非常生动的细节
but I might not remember how I got there or what happened afterwards or what I was wearing. All of those really, really clear details. Those are still very vivid in Jill's memory. I remember a time when I was running around. I must have been 12 or 13. It was it was dark. I was I think I was in a parking lot somewhere. I tripped and fell,
关于那天发生了什么。她记得听到母亲从她身边走开的声音，听到母亲高跟鞋远去的脚步声，真的是非常非常详细。现在，引人注目的是，当然，当许多年前的事情发生时，随着时间的推移，我们的记忆开始褪色。我们开始忘记其中的细节，但对于吉尔来说似乎并非如此。不，所以实际上，这很不寻常。然而，比如说，我对童年事件的记忆可能非常非常模糊，非常朦胧。我可能会记住该事件的核心细节，
I landed very hard on my finger, I broke my finger, it was very painful at the time. But now when I look back on it, I look back on it and say, that's what being a kid was, you ran around, you did silly things and you had injuries. I no longer remember the pain, I don't remember the details. To be honest, I'm not even sure which finger was actually hurt anymore. But with Jill, because she has this detailed memory, the memory is also painful in a way for her that it's not for me. Yeah, exactly. So like she's a lot of time really what's happening here is that she's constantly reliving these same experiences and kind of perseverating on them
但我可能记不清我是怎么到达那里的，或者后来发生了什么，或者我当时穿的是什么。所有那些非常非常清晰的细节。在吉尔的记忆中，这些依然非常生动。我记得有一次我在四处奔跑。我当时肯定只有12或13岁。天很黑。我想我当时在某个停车场。我被绊倒并摔倒了，
and thinking about them. And it does mean then that you're not able to let some of these things go. So we often tend to think of this kind of this kind of really extraordinary memory as being an extra gift, that it's this extra, like, wonderful thing that you have, this skill that you have. And in some ways, of course, it is. And a lot of people who have this condition or who have this ability think of it as being wonderful, but there are significant downsides. and one other way of thinking about this is that it's not so much a great ability to remember as it is an inability to forget.
我的手指狠狠地着地了，我摔断了手指，当时非常痛。但现在当我回想起这件事时，我回过头来说，这就是当孩子的样子，你四处奔跑，你做傻事，你受伤了。我不再记得那种痛苦，我也不记得细节了。说实话，我甚至不确定到底是哪根手指受伤了。但对吉尔来说，因为她有这种详细的记忆，这种记忆对她来说也是一种痛苦，而对我就不是这样。是的，完全如此。所以，就像她很多时候真正发生的情况一样，她不断地在重新经历这些相同的经历，并在这些经历上喋喋不休、反复琢磨
So Jill Price doesn't just remember this one childhood event, she remembers other things in her life. Tell me the story about her husband Jim and what happened to him, Kiera. So in the book, Jill talks a lot. Firstly, she talks a lot about how she about her husband Jim and what happened to him, Kiera. So in the book, Jill talks a lot, firstly talks a lot about how she met her husband Jim and they had been, had a long distance relationship at first and then when they met, they had this really, really strong connection and fell very deeply in love and got married and lived together and had this, from her recollection, had this wonderful marriage. But there is this extremely tragic end to it, which is that only after only two years of marriage,
并思考它们。这就意味着你无法放下其中的一些事情。所以我们经常倾向于认为这种非凡的记忆是一种额外的天赋，是某种额外的东西，是一件美妙的事情，是你所拥有的这种技能。在某些方面，当然是的。许多患有这种病症或拥有这种能力的人认为它是美妙的，但也有明显的缺点。看待这一点的另一种方式是，与其说这是一种强大的记忆能力，不如说这是一种无法遗忘的能力。
when Jim was only 42, he died. He had very severe diabetes and he suffered a stroke as a result of that and died as a result after several days in the hospital. Now, one of the things that's striking is that because Jill had such good memory, she could remember many of the good times in great detail, perhaps in much better detail than many of us could have remembered it. She remembered when she first met Jim, you know, that first night together,
所以吉尔·普莱斯不仅记得这件童年往事，她还记得她生活中的其他事情。基拉，告诉我关于她的丈夫吉姆以及他身上发生的事情的故事。所以在书中，吉尔谈了很多。首先，她谈了很多关于她丈夫吉姆以及他身上发生的事情，基拉。所以在书中，吉尔谈了很多，首先谈了她是如何遇到她的丈夫吉姆的，他们曾有过一段异地恋，然后当他们见面时，他们有着非常非常强烈的联系，并深深地相爱了，结婚了，生活在一起，而且根据她的回忆，他们拥有了一段美满的婚姻。但这其中有一个极其悲惨的结局，那就是在仅仅结婚两年之后，
what their wedding day was like. She remembered the good times in extraordinary detail, but that also meant that she remembered the tragic end in excruciating detail. Yes, exactly. And I mean, of course, many people listening might be saying, well, I remember my wedding day as well. But I think the thing is that it's not just these big key events that she remembers, it's also just everyday things. And she will remember not just our first date was great,
当吉姆只有42岁时，他去世了。他患有非常严重的糖尿病，因此中风，并在医院住了几天后不幸去世。现在，引人注目的一点是，由于吉姆的离去，吉尔拥有如此好的记忆力，她能够极其详细地记住许多美好的时光，也许比我们许多人能记住的要详细得多。她记得她第一次见到吉姆时，你知道的，他们在一起的那个夜晚，
but every detail of it in extraordinary clarity. But yes, towards the end then as well, she also cannot allow those terrible memories of Jim's illness and death to fade. So she describes in really great detail how when her father came home and told her that Jim had collapsed at work and then they're driving to the hospital and she goes through in this just exhaustive detail every phone call she made to the nurse and then the nurse is telling her this and then, you know, all these details of the drive to the hospital and then, you know, what the doctors were, you know, this horrible situation where he was in critical care for days and then eventually the doctors had to tell her they had to turn off the life support machines. The fact of this terrible thing happening is something that everyone would remember and And nobody's going to have forgotten that their husband died so tragically.
他们的婚礼是什么样的。她以非凡的细节记住了那些美好的时光，但这同时也意味着她以令人痛苦的详细程度记住了那个悲惨的结局。是的，完全如此。我的意思是，当然，许多听众可能会说，我也记得我的婚礼。但我觉得关键在于，她记住的不仅是这些重大的关键事件，还有日常琐事。她不仅会记住我们的第一次约会很棒，
But it's every little detail of it. And she says that even every time now, years and years later, she can't drive down that road where they drove to the hospital because every vivid little detail of that drive to the hospital is there, comes back, and they don't fade with time. You know, we have that cliché that time is a great healer. And we do tend to see that that over time, our negative memories tend to fade and we tend to hold on more to the positive memories.
而是以非凡的清晰度记住其中的每一个细节。但是，是的，到了接近尾声的时候，她同样无法让那些关于吉姆生病和死亡的糟糕记忆褪色。所以她以非常详尽的细节描述了当她的父亲回家告诉她吉姆在工作时晕倒了，然后他们开车去医院，她极其详尽地回顾了她给护士打的每一个电话，然后护士告诉她这些，然后，你知道的，所有开车去医院的细节，然后，你知道的，医生们当时的情况，你知道的，他在重症监护室呆了好几天，最后医生不得不告诉她必须关闭生命支持机器的这种可怕情况。发生这件可怕事情的事实是每个人都会记住的，而且
Now, there are exceptions, but Jill's memory really doesn't seem to discriminate. She holds on to all of those details, whether or not they're still relevant, whether or not they're useful to her. She's still holding on to all of those details whether or not they're still relevant, whether or not they're useful to her, she's still holding on to all of them. Kira, say more about this idea. I think when many of us think about forgetting, we think about forgetting as a flaw. You know, I find myself forgetting things all the time and whenever I forget things, I'm so upset with myself and I say, you know, I used to have a fantastic the time. And whenever I forget things, I'm so upset with myself. And I say, you know, I used to have a fantastic memory
没有人会忘记他们的丈夫死得如此悲惨。但这是其中的每一个小细节。她说，即使现在，多年后的今天，她也无法开着车驶过他们当时去医院的那条路，因为去医院的那条路的每一个生动的小细节都在那里，历历在目，而且它们不会随着时间的推移而褪色。你知道，我们有一个老生常谈的说法，时间是最好的疗伤药。我们确实倾向于看到，随着时间的推移，我们的消极记忆往往会褪色，而我们往往会更多地抓住积极记忆不放。
and now my memory is failing me. It's not good. I worry if I have a disorder of some kind. Talk about this idea that in some ways, we get it profoundly wrong when we think about forgetting as a flaw. Yeah, so I think the first thing to note is that forgetting is actually a fundamental component
当然也有例外，但吉尔的记忆似乎确实不会区别对待。她抓住了所有这些细节不放，无论它们是否仍然相关，无论它们对她是否还有用。她仍然抓住所有这些细节不放，无论它们是否仍然相关，无论它们对她是否还有用，她仍然把它们全部抓在手里。基拉，请多谈谈这个想法。我想，当我们许多人想到遗忘时，我们会把遗忘视为一种缺陷。你知道，我发现自己一直在忘事，每当我忘事时，我都对生自己的气，我说，你知道的，我曾经有过一个绝佳的时光。而每当我忘事时，我都对生自己的气。我说，你知道的，我曾经有过极好的记忆力
of memory. We tend to think of forgetting almost as the flip side of memory. And that memory is the positive, what we're supposed to do. And then forgetting is the thing that the accidental thing that happens. But that's really not the case. Like forgetting is a fundamental element of what happens in our memory processes. I think a lot of the problem here comes in that when we tend to make the mistake of thinking that our memories act like a computer system, that we should be able to just file away information and then it will stay in that same place.
，现在我的记忆力却在衰退。这可不好。我担心自己是不是得了某种疾病。谈谈这个想法：在某些方面，当我们把遗忘视为一种缺陷时，我们完全弄错了。是的，所以我想首先需要指出的是，遗忘实际上是记忆的一个基本组成部分。我们倾向于将遗忘视为记忆的反面。并且认为记忆是积极的，是我们应该做的事情。而遗忘则是偶然发生的事情。但事实并非如此。遗忘实际上是我们记忆过程中发生的事情的一个基本要素。我认为这里的大部分问题在于，当我们倾向于犯这样的错误：认为我们的记忆就像一个计算机系统，我们应该能够把信息归档，然后它就会停留在同一个地方。
And then later on, we should be able to retrieve that information and we pull it back exactly the same way it was before. And if we had a computer where we went to go and retrieve a file and the file wasn't there, it had been accidentally deleted, we'd be disgusted. That's not what a computer is supposed to do, right? A computer is supposed to retain this perfect record of information as we recorded it. But that's not what our memories do. That's not how our memories work. Rather than
然后稍后，我们应该能够检索到这些信息，并且我们以完全相同的方式把它拉回来。如果我们有一台电脑，我们去检索一个文件，而文件不在了，它被意外删除了，我们会感到恶心。电脑不该是这样的，对吧？电脑应该保留我们记录的信息的完美记录。但这并不是我们的记忆所做的事情。这并不是我们记忆的工作方式。与其把
thinking of memory as being this kind of passive process where we just file information away and then it just stays there, memory is actually this really active process where we're kind of actively engaging in our memories. We engage in actively constructing and reconstructing our memories and we change the way our memories are stored in our brains. And part of that process is that forgetting is a kind of a natural sort of digestion process in memory, that we have lots and lots of different events in our lives. And one of the really key things that our memories do and that forgetting helps us do essentially is to identify the gist of those memories.
记忆想象成一种被动的过程，即我们只是把信息归档然后它就待在那里，不如说记忆实际上是一个非常活跃的过程，我们在这个过程中积极地参与到我们的记忆中。我们积极地构建和重建我们的记忆，并改变我们的记忆在大脑中储存的方式。而这个过程的一部分就是，遗忘是记忆中一种自然的消化过程，我们在生活中经历了许许多多不同的事件。而我们的记忆所做的最关键的事情之一，以及遗忘本质上帮助我们做到的事情，就是提炼出这些记忆的要旨。
So, for example, right, like imagine every day, probably you eat breakfast. OK, and probably most days you eat more or less the same thing for breakfast. Maybe you eat something different on the weekends than you do the weekdays. OK, but probably you eat the same thing more or less every morning. You could, if you think of that computer metaphor, you could imagine that for every single day of your life you should have a perfect veridical recollection of exactly what you ate for breakfast, how you poured out the cornflakes, how you poured out the milk, how you sat down at the table, picked up your spoon, how many bites you ate, how many times you chewed each bite. But honestly, what a waste of time to remember all of these things in such detail.
所以，例如，对吧，就像想象一下，大概你每天都在吃早餐。好的，而且可能大多数日子你早餐吃的东西都差不多。也许你在周末吃的东西和工作日吃的不一样。好吧，但可能你每天早上吃的东西或多或少都是一样的。如果你用那个计算机隐喻来思考，你可以想象，对于你生命的每一天，你都应该对你早餐到底吃了什么、你是怎么倒玉米片的、你是怎么倒牛奶的、你是怎么在桌子旁坐下并拿起勺子的、你吃了多少口、每一口你嚼了多少次，有着完美而真实的记忆。但老实说，把所有这些事情都如此详细地记住，是多么浪费时间啊。
Really, all you really need to know is to sort of condense all of that information into, usually I eat cornflakes for breakfast. Okay. And then sometimes when something a little bit different happens, then we need to be able to remember that. Like, well, we ran out of milk this morning so I had toast instead. I must remember to go to the shop and buy milk. But most of the time remembering all of these very repetitive events in our lives in this perfect individual detail is actually a really inefficient way of storing information. Instead we kind of condense that information down and we pull out the gist of those kind
实际上，你真正需要知道的只是把所有这些信息浓缩成：我早餐通常吃玉米片。好的。然后有时当一些稍微不同的事情发生时，我们需要能够记住这一点。比如，好吧，我们今天早上牛奶用完了，所以我改吃吐司了。我必须记得去商店买牛奶。但大多数时候，把我们生活中所有这些高度重复的事件以完美的个人细节全部记住，实际上是一种非常低效的信息储存方式。相反，我们把这些信息浓缩起来，并提炼出那种
of repeated continuous events. So if you can't do that, if you're not able to kind of essentially leave some of those details behind you, then what you're going to have more trouble doing is identifying the gist, identifying the commonalities among all of those different events. You know, it's so striking, Kira, because I think when most of us think of memory, not just in our individual lives, but also I think in our social lives, we think of forgetting as almost being something that is bad. I mean, if you think about courtroom settings, for example, we think about people who don't remember where they were or what they were doing at the time of a crime as being potentially
重复发生的连续事件的要旨。所以如果你做不到这一点，如果你基本上无法将其中一些细节抛在脑后，那么你要做起来更困难的事情将是提炼要旨，识别所有这些不同事件之间的共同点。你知道，这太让人震撼了，基拉，因为我认为当我们大多数人想到记忆时，不仅在我们的个人生活中，而且我认为在我们的社会生活中，我们认为遗忘几乎是一件坏事。我的意思是，如果你想想法庭的场景，例如，我们会认为那些记不清在犯罪发生时自己身在何处或在做什麽的人可能是
suspicious or even guilty. Yes, absolutely. I think again, it comes back to that idea that we really have these very unrealistic expectations of what our memories can or should do. And we do tend to hold to a certain extent ourselves, but really other people to very unrealistic standards regarding their memory. And we tend to assume, for example, and there's lots of evidence of this, that in, for example, forensic or legal settings, as you've said, we tend to assume that if someone's memory changes or has gaps in it, that they're hiding something or that they're lying. That if their memory of an event changes, that shows that they're lying
可疑的甚至是有罪的。是的，完全如此。我想这再次回到了那个观点，即我们对我们的记忆能够做什么或应该做什么，确实抱有非常不切实际的期望。而且我们确实倾向于对自己，但更对其他人，在他们的记忆方面抱有非常不切实际的标准。我们倾向于假设，例如，有大量的证据表明，在例如法医或法律环境中，正如你所说的那样，我们倾向于假设如果一个人的记忆发生变化或有空白，就说明他们在隐瞒什么或者他们在撒谎。如果他们对事件的记忆发生变化，这表明他们在撒谎
about that event and that they can't be trusted. If there's a gap in their memory, maybe they're lying, maybe they can't be trusted, there's something going on. Where in fact, that is completely normal. And if somebody is actually able to give you this perfect, clear description of what happened to them, a lot of that is going to have been essentially reconstructed and rebuilt. So in fact, even the story I told you earlier on
关于那个事件，并且他们是不可信的。如果他们的记忆中出现空白，也许他们在撒谎，也许他们不可信，有什么不对劲。而事实上，这完全是正常的。如果某人真的能够给你提供一个关于他们身上发生了什么的完美、清晰的描述，其中很大一部分内容基本上是被重新构建和重建的。所以事实上，甚至我刚才早些时候讲给你的那个
about my accident and in particular, the story I told you about the incident with the ketamine and so on, I was literally under the influence of drugs. I do not have a clear memory of that, but I have a reconstructed memory of how I remember it having happened. That doesn't mean that that's actually necessarily an accurate representation of what happened. It's my reality, but it doesn't necessarily correspond to external reality. In some ways, Kiera, there's a famous Maya Angelou quote that sums up very well what you were just saying. Yeah, she says that so people will forget what you said,
关于我的事故的故事，特别是关于氯胺酮事件等的故事，我当时字面意义上正处于药物的影响之下。我对那件事没有清晰的记忆，但我有关于我记忆中这件事如何发生的重建的记忆。这并不意味着这一定是对所发生事情的准确描述。这是我的现实，但它不一定对应外部现实。在某些方面，基拉，有一句著名的玛雅·安杰洛的名言很好地总结了你刚才所说的话。是的，她说人们会忘记你说过的话，
people will forget what you did, but people will never forget how you made them feel. And I think that really is that idea again of that core aspect of what it is that we're trying to remember from events. So I remember that my bike accident was frightening and terrifying. But, you know, did I cross the white line before the back wheel went out or not? I don't know. I could probably, if I thought about that long enough, I would construct a memory in which I would tell you with certainty that I had, you know, I was on the correct side of the white line. But I, there's no guarantee that that memory is accurate. Okay. But what I can tell you with confidence is how I feel about it and about that core emotional content of the memory.
人们会忘记你做过的事，但人们永远不会忘记你带给他们的感受。我认为这确实是那个观点，即我们试图从事件中记住的内容的核心方面的那个核心层面。所以我记得我的自行车事故是令人恐惧和可怕的。但是，你知道的，在后轮打滑之前我有没有越过白线？我不知道。如果我仔细思考足够长的时间，我可能会构建一段记忆，并在其中极其确凿地告诉你我当时，你知道的，我在白线的正确一侧。但是，我，这并不能保证那段记忆是准确的。好吧。但我能满怀信心地告诉你的是我对它的感受，以及这段记忆的核心情感内容。
You know, I also find it a little amusing that people remember that quote as coming from Maya Angelou when in fact it probably predated her. So the feeling that it was from Maya Angelou sticks in our head more than the fact of whether it actually was from her or not. Well, yeah, that's the case with it with a lot of famous quotes is that they get, I mean, I'd say 90% of the quotes on the Internet are attributed to Oscar Wilde. And I mean, the man said a lot of things, but he didn't say everything. When we come back, how evolution has sculpted our brains to quickly forget certain painful events. If you had that Jill Price-like perfect vivid memory of that first pregnancy, you might be more likely to say,
你知道，我也觉得有点好笑，人们把那句话记成是玛雅·安杰洛说的，但实际上它可能比她还要早。所以，比起它是不是真的是她说的这个事实，它出自玛雅·安杰洛之手的印象在我们脑海中根深蒂固。好吧，是的，很多名言都是这样，它们被，我的意思是，我想说互联网上90%的名言都归功于奥斯卡·王尔德。我的意思是，这位先生说过很多话，但他并没有包揽一切。当我们回来时，我们将探讨进化如何重塑我们的大脑，使其能迅速忘记某些痛苦的事件。如果你拥有像吉尔·普赖斯那样完美而生动的第一次怀孕记忆，你可能更有可能说，
there's absolutely no way I'm ever doing that again. That was like a horror movie. I'm not doing it again. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. There's no shortage of tips for how to improve your memory. Exercise more, meditate, try a crossword puzzle. We all want to boost our memory and curb our forgetfulness. At University College Dublin, Keira Green studies the science of memory. In her book with Gillian Murphy,
绝对不可能再经历一次了。那就像恐怖电影一样。我再也不要经历了。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。关于如何改善记忆力的建议从来都不缺。多运动、冥想、尝试填字游戏。我们都想增强记忆力并减少健忘。在都柏林大学学院，基拉·格林研究着记忆科学。在与吉莉安·墨菲合著的书籍中，
Memory Lane, The Perfectly Imperfect Ways We Remember, Keira explores all the ways memory can fail us, but also all the ways it can be strengthened. She says that forgetting is not the opposite of memory. In fact, it plays a crucial role in how our brains function. It's a vital part of living a healthy life. So Kira, you and Gillian Murphy were working on a project together
《记忆小径：我们记忆的完美不完美方式》中，基拉探讨了记忆可能欺骗我们的种种方式，同时也探讨了它可以被强化的所有途径。她表示，遗忘并不是记忆的反面。事实上，它在我们的脑部功能运作中起着至关重要的作用。这是过上健康生活不可或缺的一部分。所以基拉，你和吉莉安·墨菲当时正在合作一个项目，
and I understand Gillian was pregnant. Tell me a little bit about that. I understand it was a difficult pregnancy? Yes, so Gillian was pregnant with her second child and she was really sick, as a lot of people are. She just had appalling morning sickness which was not restricted to the morning. She was just sick all the time. She felt absolutely miserable. She was saying to me and to her husband and anybody who'd listen how miserable this was. I remember her telling me that this was just so miserable and it had not
据我所了解，吉莉安那时怀孕了。能跟我稍微谈谈那个情况吗？我听说那是一次艰难的怀孕？是的，吉莉安当时怀着她的第二个孩子，她病得很厉害，就像很多人那样。她只是害喜得厉害，而且这种孕吐并不局限于早晨。她几乎无时无刻不在生病。她感觉糟透了。她一直在对我说、对她丈夫以及任何愿意听的人倾诉这有多么痛苦。我记得她告诉我，这实在是太痛苦了，而且
been anything like this bad the last time. And what was different with this pregnancy when it hadn't been this bad the last time? And I was listening to this in incredulity and I was just saying, like, Gillian, are you mad? It was just this bad the last time. I remember it. We were working together. We were good friends.
上一次可一点也没有这么糟糕。这次怀孕有什么不同，为什么上一次没有这么严重呢？我听着这些感到难以置信，我就说，吉莉安，你疯了吗？上一次明明就这么糟糕。我都记得。我们当时一起工作。我们是好朋友。
Your first pregnancy was terrible. You were so sick. You were in bits. Your first pregnancy was terrible. You were so sick. You were, you were in bits. And her husband was saying the same. Her husband was saying like, are you kidding? You couldn't get out of bed when you were pregnant the first time. It was so bad. You know, as, as memory researchers, both of you are, are study the, the science of
你的第一次怀孕太可怕了。你病得那么重。你整个人都崩溃了。你的第一次怀孕太可怕了。你病得那么重。你，你整个人都崩溃了。她的丈夫也这么说。她丈夫说，你在开玩笑吗？你第一次怀孕的时候根本下不了床。太严重了。你知道，作为记忆研究人员，你们两个都在研究
memory. What did you notice about this? What did you observe about the fact that she seemed to have completely forgotten what the first pregnancy was like? I do tend to look at everything through this lens, so I just think it was absolutely fascinating how her memory of that had been distorted. And what always seemed obvious to me and to Gillian in retrospect was that her memory had not been distorted in a completely random way. It had been distorted in a very systematic way. And if we think about the purpose of evolution at its bare core, of allowing us to propagate our genes, allowing us to reproduce, you could think about that idea that would anybody ever
记忆科学。你对此注意到了什么？关于她似乎完全忘记了第一次怀孕是什么样子的这一现象，你观察到了什么？我确实倾向于透过这个视角看待一切，所以我只是觉得她对那段经历的记忆是如何被扭曲的，绝对令人着迷。我和吉莉安事后觉得显而易见的是，她的记忆并非以一种完全随机的方式被扭曲。它是以一种非常系统化的方式被扭曲的。如果我们从进化最核心的目的来考虑，即允许我们繁衍基因、允许我们生殖，你可以思考这样一个想法：如果一个人记得第一次生孩子有多糟糕，还会不会
have a second child if they remembered how bad it was the first time around? So that maybe there is an evolutionary benefit or a functional benefit to misremembering or forgetting some of those negative experiences because it allows us to move forward with our lives. But there is some evidence suggesting that actually this is true, that women who are trying to get pregnant or want to have a second child do misremember the difficulties of their first pregnancy and of their first childbirth, that they will kind of dial down the negative elements of that and that sort of supports them to be able to kind of just
有人愿意生第二个孩子？所以，选择性地记错或遗忘其中一些负面经历，可能存在某种进化上的好处或功能上的好处，因为它能让我们带着生活继续向前。但确实有一些证据表明，事实确实如此，那些试图怀孕或想要第二个孩子的女性确实会记错她们第一次怀孕和第一次分娩时的困难，她们会某种程度上淡化其中的负面因素，而这某种程度上支持了她们能够
even mentally deal with the idea of doing it again. There's a very popular movie series about a girl named Riley. The premise of the Inside Out movie series is to personify the different processes unfolding inside Riley's head. In one scene, characters are playing different emotions in Riley's head and they go through her old memories, discarding unused piano lessons, the names of most of the US presidents, even the names of Riley's favorite childhood toys. So the movie suggests that one purpose of forgetting is a form of decluttering. Is that right, Keira? To an extent. I mean, it's not the case necessarily that we're actually just taking memories and
甚至在心理上应对再次经历这一切的想法。有一部非常受欢迎的电影系列，讲的是一个叫莱莉的女孩。这部《头脑特工队》电影系列的设定是将莱莉脑海中展开的不同过程进行拟人化。在一个场景中，角色们在莱莉的脑海中扮演不同的情绪，他们翻看她旧的记忆，丢弃废弃的钢琴课、大部分美国总统的名字，甚至莱莉童年最喜欢的玩具的名字。所以电影暗示，遗忘的一个目的是一种清理杂物（断舍离）的形式。是这样吗，基拉？在某种程度上是这样的。我的意思是，这并不一定意味着我们实际上只是把记忆拿出来，
taking them out and putting them away. But certainly we are kind of combining things together and digesting them in such a way that we're kind of clearing up some kind of mental space. Now, when I say mental space, I don't mean long term memory storage. We actually do have you know, quite like the ability to store a huge amount of information. A lot of the time when we talk about not being able to remember something, it's not that that memory isn't there anywhere. It's that we don't have an easy route to access it. So you can think about, if you think about how memories are formed in the brain, they're formed by synapses forming connections between different neurons.
然后把它们拿走并收好。但可以肯定的是，我们正在以某种方式将事物组合在一起并进行消化，从而腾出某种心理空间。现在，当我谈到心理空间时，我指的不是长期记忆存储。我们实际上确实拥有，你知道，储存大量信息的能力。很多时候，当我们谈论无法记住某事时，并不是那个记忆根本不在那里。而是我们没有一条便捷的途径去访问它。所以你可以这样想，如果你思考记忆是如何在大脑中形成的，它们是由不同神经元之间形成突触连接而成的。
So we create these networks of connections between different neurons in the brain. And some of those networks have lots and lots of connections to them. So there's like lots and lots of roads or routes to that particular memory, lots of paths by which we can access it. But some of our memories are kind of those networks are a little less dense and there are fewer connections to them. So we don't have as many kind of easy routes to them. So they're kind of less easily accessed in a lot of ways.
因此我们在大脑中创造了这些不同神经元之间的连接网络。其中一些网络拥有非常多的连接。因此，通往那个特定记忆的道路或途径有很多很多，有许多我们可以访问它的路径。但我们的一些记忆，这些网络稍微没那么密集，连接也更少。因此我们没有那么多便捷的途径通往它们。所以在很多方面，它们相对来说没那么容易被访问。
And that's kind of that feeling that sometimes we have where, you know, you're walking down a street and then something, it could be a smell or a sight or just something really small triggers a memory that you haven't thought of for years and years and years. And that is, you know, it was some memory, some kind of something that was stored in such a way that it had relatively few connections to other parts of your memory. And then but then something you essentially accidentally found yourself on the road to
这就是那种我们有时会有的感觉，你知道的，你走在一条街上，然后某样东西，可能是一种气味、一个景象，或者只是一些非常微小的东西，触发了一个你已经很多年、很多年、很多年没有想过的记忆。而那就是，你知道的，那是某种记忆，某种以这样一种方式存储的东西：它与你记忆的其他部分只有相对较少的连接。然后，但是随后某种东西让你基本上意外地踏上了通往
that memory and you're retrieving it. So, you know, when we think about that kind of inside out idea of decluttering the memory, in some ways, yeah, that that does happen to an extent that we are condensing down kind of the gist, you know, so out of all this list of US presidents, for example, which ones do I actually need to remember? And which of them can I just collate into a list of, there was a load of other guys who were probably all called Andrew. So I could not tell you the names of more than about six US presidents. So there's ways that we can condense down what's actually going to be really important here. Talk about some of the emotional reasons we have for forgetting. What is the link between negative memories and psychological disorders like depression?
那个记忆的道路，于是你把它检索出来了。所以，你知道，当我们想到《头脑特工队》中清理记忆杂物的那个概念时，在某些方面，是的，这确实在某种程度上发生了，我们在精简出大致的主旨，你知道的，所以在所有这些美国总统的名单中，例如，哪些是我实际上需要记住的？其中哪些我可以简单地归纳成一个列表，里面有一堆其他人，他们可能都叫安德鲁。所以我无法告诉你大约六位以上美国总统的名字。因此，有几种方法可以让我们精简出这里面真正重要的东西。谈谈我们想要遗忘的一些情感原因。负面记忆与抑郁等心理障碍之间有什么联系？
People on average tend to remember positive events more than negative events over time. We tend to kind of let a lot of the negative stuff go and keep a lot of the positive stuff. So we'll tend to kind of remember that we got better grades when we were in school, or we'll tend to remember that we were more generous than we were, that we gave more money to charity, that we were more helpful to other people, that we, you know, did things that, you know, will make us look good. And there's some really nice work showing that it isn't just that we do this in a way that it makes us look good to other people. It's also that it makes us look good to ourselves. So for example, there was a really nice study looking at grades where people were asked to remember their grades. But in this study, they knew that the researchers had access
随着时间的推移，人们平均倾向于记住积极的事件，而不是消极的事件。我们倾向于让许多消极的事情过去，而保留许多积极的事情。所以我们往往会记得我们在学校时成绩更好，或者我们会记得我们比实际更慷慨，我们向慈善机构捐了更多的钱，我们对其他人更有帮助，我们，你知道的，做过那些让我们看起来很好的事情。有一些非常棒的研究表明，我们这样做不仅仅是为了在别人面前看起来不错。它也让我们在自己面前看起来不错。例如，曾有一项非常出色的研究调查了成绩，人们被要求回忆他们的成绩。但在这次研究中，他们知道研究人员可以获取
to their actual scores. But even so, when people were asked to retrieve, you know, what were your grades like? And people who had gotten As would remember them really well. People who had gotten Ds did not remember them well. They remember that they had gotten Bs or Cs, even though they knew, the researchers knew the real data. So it wasn't a matter of, I'm going to slightly smudge this because I know there's a reason why I didn't do well there, but they don't need to know.
他们的真实分数。即便如此，当人们被要求回忆，你知道，你的成绩怎么样？那些得过A的人能把它们记得很好。得过D的人则记不太好。他们记得自己得过B或C，尽管他们知道，研究人员掌握了真实数据。所以这并不是说，“我要稍微掩盖一下，因为我知道我没考好是有原因的，但他们不需要知道。”
You know they know. So your memory is actually being distorted to make you feel like you were a better student than you were, or you were more generous or kinder or whatever. I understand that in that study the people remember their A grades accurately 89% of the time, but they remember their D grades only 29% of the time. Yeah, exactly. And this is, I suppose, it's kind of slightly tied into that idea that, you know, everybody is a better than average driver. Nobody is thinking of themselves as being a terrible driver. Nobody is thinking of themselves as, you know, oh, I was really only ever just average.
你知道他们知道。所以你的记忆实际上被扭曲了，让你觉得你是一个比实际更好的学生，或者你更慷慨、更善良，诸如此类。我听说在那项研究中，人们有89%的时间能准确记住他们的A等成绩，但他们只有29%的时间能记住他们的D等成绩。对，完全正确。而且我认为，这在某种程度上与那个观点有点联系，你知道的，每个人都觉得自己是高于平均水平的司机。没有人认为自己是个糟糕的司机。没有人认为自己，你知道，“哦，我其实一直都只是个平庸之辈。”
But of course, this varies with a number of different things. So for example, with people who have depression, that tends to be a little bit less the case. And one of the things that we can think about when we think about how our emotion interacts with our memory is that if we think about how our memories are very associative. OK, so I talked earlier on about that idea of you're walking down the street and something triggers a memory. A lot of our memory works in the same way in a lot of different contexts. And one of the things that's really interesting from an emotional context is that we tend
但当然，这会随着许多不同的因素而变化。例如，对于患有抑郁症的人来说，情况往往不那么明显。当我们思考情感如何与记忆相互作用时，我们可以考虑的一点是，我们的记忆具有高度的联想性。好吧，所以我早些时候谈到了那个走在街上有什么东西触发了记忆的想法。我们的许多记忆在许多不同的语境中都以同样的方式运作。从情感语境来看，非常有趣的一点是，我们倾向于
to retrieve memories that are congruent with our current emotional state. So if I'm currently feeling very happy, I'm more likely to be able to remember events when I was happy. If I'm feeling sad or depressed, I'm more likely to be able to retrieve memories from my life that are sad or depressing. And then what that will mean is that I'll have a kind of slightly skewed perspective of my life, that I'll tend to view my life as being glass half empty instead of glass half full. OK, so this idea that that's referred to as a schema that we have, we create these schemas, these sort of mental frameworks that we use to store
检索与我们当前情绪状态相一致的记忆。所以如果我现在感觉非常快乐，我就更有可能记起我快乐时的经历。如果我感到悲伤或抑郁，我就更有可能从生活中检索出悲伤或令人沮丧的记忆。这意味着我对生活的视角会稍微有些扭曲，我会倾向于认为生活是半空而非半满。好吧，所以这个概念被称为我们拥有的一种图式，我们创造了这些图式，这些我们用来在记忆中存储
lots of information in our memory. One model of depression is that depression is caused by a kind of a negative schema. So essentially a way of seeing the world that tends to characterise things as very negative, both in the moment, but also in terms of how we were, the kinds of memories that we're retrieving. So somebody with depression might have more difficulty retrieving positive memories, and we'll find that they keep drifting into thinking about the more negative side. And then because they'll do that,
大量信息的心理框架。抑郁症的一种模型是，抑郁症是由一种消极图式引起的。本质上，这是一种看待世界的习惯方式，往往将事情描述为非常负面的，既体现在当下，也体现在我们检索的记忆类型方面。所以患有抑郁症的人可能在检索积极记忆时遇到更多困难，并且我们会发现他们不断陷入对消极一面的思考中。然后因为他们会这样做，
then we'll have another cognitive bias that will say, okay, if I retrieve, let's say, six memories from my life and four of the memories that I retrieve are really sad ones, I must've had a really sad life. And that may well be true, but it can also be influenced by the fact that that bias is leading you to retrieve those memories in the first place and then leading you to kind of overinterpret the frequency of those as being representative of your life as a whole. I understand there was one study which provided people either critical information about them or critical information about another person, but
接着我们就会产生另一种认知偏差，它会说：“好吧，如果我从我的生活中检索，比方说，六个记忆，而我检索的四个记忆都是非常悲伤的，那我一定过着非常悲伤的生活。”这可能确实是真的，但它也可能受到这种偏差的影响：这种偏差首先引导你检索这些记忆，然后又引导你过度解读这些记忆的频率，认为它们代表了你生活的全部。据我所知，曾有一项研究：向人们提供关于他们的批评性信息，或者关于另一个人的批评性信息，但是
when they were asked to recall what this critical information was down the road, people had better recall for the critical information when it was about somebody else as opposed to when it was about them. And that seems like almost an act of self-preservation here. Yes. So in this study, they had the participants read descriptions of a person and the description would include both positive and negative traits of the person. So they might describe the person as being kind, but sometimes they're a bit dishonest. OK. And so, you know, all the kind of things that we all are to a greater or lesser extent,
当他们在日后被要求回忆这些批评性信息是什么时，人们对批评性信息的记忆力更好——如果这些信息是关于别人的，而不是关于他们自己的。这在这里看起来几乎是一种自我保护的行为。是的。在这项研究中，他们让参与者阅读对某个人的描述，描述中既包括这个人的积极特征，也包括消极特征。所以他们可能会把这个人描述为善良，但有时有点不诚实。好吧。所以，你知道，所有这些我们或多或少都具备的特质，
everybody's a bit of a mixed bag. And then the participants were later told that this is a description either of you, so other people have described you in this way, or it's a description of some other third party, okay, what they called Chris. And then later on they asked the participants to recall as much of the description as they could. And what they found is that when people recalled the Chris study, they recalled kind of both the positive and the negative details.
每个人都是个综合体。然后，参与者后来被告知，这段描述要么是关于你自己的——也就是其他人是这样描述你的——要么是关于其他某个第三方的，好吧，他们称之为克里斯。随后，他们要求参与者尽可能多地回忆这段描述。他们发现，当人们回忆关于克里斯的研究时，他们既能回忆起积极的细节，也能回忆起消极的细节。
But if the description was supposed to apply to themselves, then they only really recalled the positive details and they were much less likely to recall the negative ones. So again, we have this sort of systematic thing where we're likely to remember the part where somebody said, oh, well, you know, she's a very kind person, but not the part where they said, well, she's sometimes a bit sneaky. So other researchers found that we tend to forget more if we cannot do anything about a particular memory. Talk about this research, Kiera, what does it find? Yeah. So again, if we take that that same idea of, you know, giving people
但如果这段描述本意是指他们自己，那么他们实际上只回忆起了积极的细节，而回忆起消极细节的可能性要小得多。所以再次地，我们有这样一种系统化的现象：我们倾向于记住别人说“哦，好吧，你知道，她是一个非常善良的人”的那部分，却记不住他们说“嗯，她有时有点鬼祟”的那部分。其他研究人员发现，如果我们无法对某段特定的记忆做任何事情，我们往往会更容易忘记它。基拉，谈谈这项研究，它发现了什么？是的。同样，如果我们采用那个相同的想法，即给人们
like a summary of that description of themselves or of somebody else that includes both positive and negative traits. The extent to which people will remember those seems to depend on whether or not people think that those are things that they can change or not. Okay. So if people think that these kind of negative traits are kind of malleable, then you know, then they're like, okay, well, that's fine. Maybe I still have those, but it's kind of something I can fix.
比如关于他们自己或别人的那份描述的摘要，其中包含积极和消极的特征。人们记住这些特征的程度似乎取决于人们是否认为这些是他们能够改变的事情。好吧。所以，如果人们认为这些消极特征在某种程度上是可塑的，那么，你知道，他们就会想，“好吧，那没关系。也许我身上还有这些，但这是我可以解决的问题。”
But if it's something that's completely like kind of, you know, something that you can't do anything about, like, oh, well, she's a nice person, but she's very really, unfortunately, short and there's absolutely nothing you can do about that. Well, then you're likely to forget that detail coming in. But if they say like, oh, well, she's a she's a really nice person. But sometimes, you know, she has a habit of rolling her eyes. You kind of go, OK, well, I could probably change that. So you could say, oh, I suppose sometimes I do do that, but I'm working on it.
但如果这是一件完全像，你知道的，你无能为力的事情，比如，“哦，好吧，她是个好人，但不幸的是她真的很矮，而你对此绝对无能为力。”好吧，那你很可能会把这个细节给忘掉。但如果他们说，“哦，好吧，她是个非常好的人。但有时，你知道，她有翻白眼的习惯。”你可能会想，“好吧，我大概可以改变这一点。”所以你可以说，“哦，我想有时我确实会那样做，但我正在努力改掉它。”
You know, so we're less likely to misremember or to forget those details where we feel like there's something that we can change or something we can do about them, and they don't feel like they're a fundamental part of who we are. What I love about what you're doing here, Kira, is that you're really showing how forgetting is actually very often functional. Absolutely. Yeah. So we really we really think it is. And I think that's one of our key messages is that, yeah, that forgetting is is not just a side effect of memory. It's not memory failing.
你知道的，所以对于那些我们觉得可以改变、可以做些什么，而且不觉得它们是我们本质一部分的细节，我们不太可能会记错或遗忘。基拉，我最喜欢你在这里所做的一点是，你真正展示了遗忘实际上往往是如何具有功能的。绝对的。是的。所以我们真的，我们真的认为它是这样的。我认为这是我们的核心信息之一，即遗忘不仅仅是记忆的副作用。它不是记忆失效。
It's part of what memory is supposed to do. And the forgetting is functional. It helps us to see the gist among different things. It helps us to recognize kind of what's important to us and what isn't. It helps us to hold on to the things that really support us to live our lives. So like if we think about not just like what memory is, but what memory is for. That memory isn't something that was just kind of created out of whole cloth. It's something that we evolved and we evolved all the kind of physical and the mental attributes that we have evolved are things that have survived evolution because they offer us some
它是记忆理应发挥作用的一部分。遗忘是具有功能的。它帮助我们在不同的事物中看出大意。它帮助我们识别什么对我们重要，什么不重要。它帮助我们留住那些真正支持我们生活的核心事物。因此，如果我们不仅思考记忆是什么，还要思考记忆是为了什么。记忆并非凭空捏造出来的东西。它是我们进化而来的产物，我们进化出的所有那些身体和心理属性之所以能在进化中存活下来，是因为它们为我们提供了
kind of benefit for either survival or for reproduction. So all of these kind of what we see as memory distortions or memory errors or sometimes called memory sins. All of these things that sometimes are annoying to us, but actually really a lot of these are things that we have evolved to be able to do and they are functional. They support us to live, thrive and survive. So that they help us to be happier. And if we look at things like mental health, being happy, having good mental health has
某种生存或繁衍上的益处。所以所有这些我们视为记忆扭曲、记忆错误、或者有时被称为记忆罪孽的东西。所有这些有时让我们感到烦恼的事情，实际上其中很大一部分是我们进化出能够做到的功能，并且它们是具有功能的。它们支持我们生活、繁衍并生存。它们帮助我们变得更快乐。如果我们看看心理健康之类的事情，快乐、拥有良好的心理健康具有
huge survival advantages. look at things like mental health and being happy, having good mental health has huge survival advantages. So we know that people who are happier live longer, they're healthier, you know, all of these things. So it's not just a kind of touchy-feely, oh, I'll feel better. It's like these things actually have survival benefits. Kira and other researchers have found that even our pernicious tendency to remember negative things about our political opponents and positive things about our political allies, even this likely has functional benefits from an evolutionary point of view, even if it might be bad for democracy.
巨大的生存优势。看看心理健康和快乐之类的事情，拥有良好的心理健康具有巨大的生存优势。所以我们知道，更快乐的人活得更久，更健康，你知道的，所有这些。所以这不仅仅是一种感性的“哦，我会感觉更好”。而是这些事情实际上具有生存益处。基拉和其他研究人员发现，即使是我们对政治对手倾向于记住负面事情、对政治盟友倾向于记住正面事情这种有害倾向，从进化的角度来看也可能具有功能上的益处，尽管它可能对民主有害。
So we have a lot of work looking at, say, false memories for fake news, showing that people, firstly, that people can very easily form false memories. If I show you a news story about like a political scandal that never happened, there's a fairly decent chance that you will go, oh yeah, yeah, I remember that. And you'll tell me where you remember it from and how you felt at the time and all kinds of things, okay, even though we just made it up. But what we find really consistently is that that is way more likely if that story is congruent with your existing ideological views. So if it's a story is congruent with your existing ideological views. So if it's a story that reflects well on your group or reflects badly on the other side,
所以我们有很多研究，例如针对假新闻的虚假记忆，研究表明：首先，人们非常容易形成虚假记忆。如果我向你展示一篇从未发生过的政治丑闻的新闻报道，你有相当大的可能会说，“哦，是的，是的，我记得那个。”然后你会告诉我你从哪里记起它的、当时的感觉以及各种各样的细节，好吧，尽管我们刚刚是捏造出来的。但我们非常一致地发现，如果这个故事与你现有的意识形态观点相符，你更有可能产生这种记忆。所以，如果这是一个
you're much more likely to form a false memory for that than you are if it reflects well on the other team or reflects badly on your team. And again, that is part of that idea where we think it's a part of kind of shoring up those social bonds, that we're kind of reinforcing that sense of identity with our social groups. And you know, being part of a social group is again a hugely important survival factor. Humans are social animals. We don't survive well on our own. We live as part of a society.
对你的群体有正面反映、或对另一方有负面反映的故事，你比它对另一支队伍有正面反映或对你们队伍有负面反映时，更有可能为它形成虚假记忆。再次，这构成了我们认为它有助于巩固社会纽带这一理念的一部分，我们在强化与社会群体的认同感。而且，你知道，成为社会群体的一部分同样是一个极其重要的生存因素。人类是社会性动物。我们靠自己很难生存。我们作为社会的一部分生活。
And being integrated in a society and feeling part of a social group is a hugely important part of our psychological makeup. One practical implication of all this research, Keira says, is that we should look at our own memories with skepticism and our own forgetfulness with compassion. Indeed, just observing how our biases shape what we remember and what we forget can change how we feel about painful memories. We kind of tend to see our thoughts and believe in our thoughts as objective reality, and sometimes kind of there's a therapeutic technique called diffusion that's about trying to take that step back.
融入社会并感受到自己是社会群体的一部分，是我们心理构成中至关重要的一部分。基拉说，所有这些研究的一个实际启示是，我们应该以怀疑的眼光看待自己的记忆，以富有同情心的态度看待自己的健忘。事实上，仅仅观察我们的偏见如何塑造我们所记住的和遗忘的内容，就能改变我们对痛苦记忆的感受。我们往往倾向于将自己的思想视为客观现实并对其深信不疑，有时存在一种名为“解离（认知解离）”的治疗技术，它旨在尝试退后一步。
So put it simply, it's that idea of to recognize your own thoughts and to reflect on them. So to kind of to see things like saying, for example, you might have the thought, I'm a failure. Okay. You can either say like, well, that means I am a failure, as in this thought has objective reality, or you can take a step back and say and recognize that no, I'm having the thought that I'm a failure. That actually doesn't mean that I am, I just recognize that I'm having that thought.
简单来说，就是认识到你自己的思想并对其进行反思的想法。所以去看到诸如这样的话，例如，你脑海中可能会浮现这个想法：“我是一个失败者。”好吧。你要么会说，“嗯，这意味着我就是一个失败者，”就好像这个想法具有客观现实一样；要么你可以退后一步，说并意识到：“不，我只是脑子里有‘我是一个失败者’这个想法。”这实际上并不意味着我就是，我只是意识到我脑子里有这个想法。
And just taking that little bit of distance and recognizing that not every thought that you have necessarily holds objective truth. That you can take that distance from them and say, look observe my thoughts, observe how my thoughts are working, observe the patterns that they go in, and then recognize that. Can we really put painful memories to rest or prevent them from getting deeply anchored in the brain? Research suggests there might be a sweet spot when it comes to forgetting. Try too hard to forget a painful memory and you could end up strengthening it. If you're subscribed to HiddenBrain Plus, that episode is available for you right now. It's titled, Setting the Past to Rest.
只要保持这一点点距离，并认识到你脑海中的每一个想法并不一定都包含客观真理。你可以与它们保持距离并说：“看，观察我的思想，观察我的思想是如何运作的，观察它们遵循的模式，然后认识到这一点。”我们真的能让痛苦的记忆歇息，或者阻止它们在大脑中深深扎根吗？研究表明，在遗忘方面可能存在一个最佳平衡点。过度努力去忘记痛苦的记忆，结果反而可能会强化它。如果你订阅了《隐藏的大脑Plus》，那一集现在就可以收听了。它的标题是《让过去安息》。
If you're not yet subscribed, please sign up at support.hiddenbrain.org. If you have an Apple device, go to apple.co. slash hiddenbrain. In both places, you can get a free seven-day trial. Keira Green is a psychologist at University College Dublin. With Gillian Murphy, she's the author of the book, Memory Lane, the perfectly imperfect ways we remember. Kira, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar. Do you have follow-up questions about memory and forgetting for Kira Green?
如果你还没有订阅，请在 support.hiddenbrain.org 上注册。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问 apple.co/hiddenbrain。在这两个地方，你都可以获得为期七天的免费试用。基拉·格林是都柏林大学学院的心理学家。她与吉莉安·墨菲合著了《记忆小径：我们记忆的完美不完美方式》一书。基拉，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，尚卡尔。你对基拉·格林关于记忆和遗忘还有后续问题吗？
If you'd be comfortable sharing those questions with a Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, memory. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirrell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury.
如果你愿意与《隐藏的大脑》的听众分享这些问题，请在手机上录制语音备忘录并通过电子邮件发送给我们，邮箱地址是 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。邮件地址再重复一遍：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。请使用“记忆”作为主题行。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保尔、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥秋恩·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。
Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Thanks for listening. See you soon. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制作人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。感谢收听。再见。你 本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。